hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
I'm John Humphrey we came across a
couple of articles I've only read the
titles for them one was sent to our
Facebook another one I saw in Collider
they're gonna be about the opening scene
in the after credits scene I'd have it
both originally different Justice League
Justice League
I love this movie and I really want to
see all the alternate versions I want I
want there to be three cuts
everybody I want I want them to Joss
Whedon with Zack Snyder the WBT
Danny Elfman gets the Excel also get to
cut it just need a bunch of different
cuts now because it sounds like everyone
just kept remaking this movie so Justice
League's opening scene was originally
comedic says Holtz and the colony old
Mokelumne plays I forgot his name but
he's my favorite wine on my adulterous
bill so here is a quote from molt Holton
I love Joss Whedon I see with that bad
it's such a deep voice I conceived it
conceived as a comedic see I just want
to go dress like a bet that's how Joss
wrote it and that's how we shot it I
thought it came out great but the studio
felt it would be a mistake to open the
film with a completely comedic scene so
I was reading it a little bit I was
disappointed but when I got home New
York and I found a bottle of my favorite
champagne and know from Joss that said
two battles lost gratefully Joss
Wow that's it that's a deep sentence
right there [ __ ] how many battles is
that one scene I can't tell you how much
it meant to me they took the time to
write to me Joss Whedon is a class act I
had the letter frame petition would say
otherwise I got like two opinions about
that I think it was smart the way it
started off with that scene I felt a
little choppy
it does make you kind of go why was this
guy yeah what was this guy Katherine
wait
yeah what is what was the point if we're
having a whole colony there when he's
such a fantastic actor a grand and this
is before mine hunter debuted so maybe
he just wasn't as well no no this was
like the smaller role he got what bums
me out about this is I know how talented
of an actor holding the colony is I
would have loved to see the original
scene because it sounds like he actually
used his talents and it was worthy
enough for Joss Whedon to be like dude
I'm sorry we had to cut it down but here
you go
extended cut of the scene I really do
love that scene even though some parts
of the action moments feel a bit choppy
I really like that same beak and I think
it's smart that it starts off on a
darker so I feel like WB might have had
a good instinct about that if that was a
studios decision because if it started
off just just like that I feel like it
would have felt very off to be honest
yeah yeah that's kind of how I felt too
and thinking back on it I did appreciate
the tone of the opening scene you know
yeah I thought it was appropriately
lighter but still you know brooding and
gone yeah yeah you know and I like that
they did that so yeah I'm not altogether
bummed that wasn't comedic I am bummed
that it had to be a chop yeah because of
this whoa this is way for the Joss
Whedon
I don't necessarily think that yeah
Batman being funny should be the first
no no I just don't think that right no
you know I elaborate a lotta time when I
talked about my second viewing
experience of how it was the film works
really well in the sense of how it
doesn't start off super light and super
heroic and comedic at first it gets more
light as it progresses which I think
works better for an overall film
especially when this is your
transitional movie what also depends on
what they mean by comedic so you know
like in what way they think Batman
hearts on it like a good fart joke right
classy comedy here okay and then the
other article from comic book calm a
visual effects artist talked about it
the original after credit scene that was
shot in principal photography was Bruce
being woken the night in his lake house
by a green light and visited by Toma
ray and Kilowog it was cut fairly early
on during post I mean that would have
been a cooler cameo I guess in terms of
the after credit scene but I also kind
of get what DC didn't lose that no one's
really gonna know who those guys are
live Lantern you'll be like the Green
Lantern's he you know you'll know that I
wouldn't say Deathstroke is like as
popular as a Batman of course with the
video games and of course the comics and
then having Deathstroke and the arrow
show death starts become a lot more
known so having that as an after credit
scene it works way better I think and
you do see the lanterns in the big
battle so you do tease it yeah where
they will eventually use them I think
this might have worked cooler if if the
lanterns weren't originally in the back
if you usually see it and then they show
up at the end then that would have been
cool yeah sure I don't know this is
another one where I kind of I kind of
feel them on this one I like that we saw
them in the battle hinting that they're
in the averse but we're not gonna make a
big deal out of it because I think it's
nice to keep it focused and it was more
like an easter egg at that point yeah
you're supposed to promote big deal man
I kind of dig that they kept it more in
the world of the black movies if I
insulted anyone by saying that tomorrow
oh bugger not big characters I'm sorry I
hope you actually get what I freaking
mean to the common folk I mean with
everything we've been talking about with
Justice League doing a spoiler video and
me doing a second viewing video and that
we even did that whole petition video
where we talked a lot about how there's
a plenty of deleted scenes a lot of
those scenes I've heard of and seen
footage of like behind the scenes
footage and by going over the trailers
going where is that city looks so cool
is that you know even the whole final
battle they show shots of that in the
other trailers and it's totally dark but
in post when they were before releasing
it they changed it all red and bright
and everything you know and which gave
it a cool is still a cool look I like
the look of it and and I think that the
whole fan I works
on IMAX specifically this is so
different here's what I'll say with
these two scenes I would like to see
these scenes but I'm not upset they're
not in the movie yeah I don't feel like
they were absolutely necessary
I don't feel robbed that I haven't seen
them yeah like you know Oh neat if
that's on the DVD I'll check that yeah
yeah yeah if anything between the two I
would much rather see whole two McCallum
Acala
McAllister Callen the thing is because
jaspion son this time like they must
have put a lot of more work into that
scene and that actor has to have [ __ ]
really trimmed down like a lot of the
actors in the film but he only has this
one scene you know and I'm like oh come
on I only have one scene I want to see
this guy's fools II really have one
scene let's see if they do right by the
the work they put in yeah cuz it seems
like you know good amount of a few
people's where it got taken out of just
ya cuz as much as I love the film I
would like to see the deleted scenes in
the extended versus one movie where I'm
genuinely interested in seeing all those
scenes yeah yeah it sounds like that
could be a special edition you remember
when Mike T - special edition came out
wasn't director's cut special edition
was like this is the the more epic
version of the Terminator 2 which was
already Attica you know and I feel like
this could be a special edition I think
there's a different feeling that goes to
special edition as opposed to director's
cut although I think you should call
this director's cut cuz you had it's a
hold the bago between what our is
accents what our Joseph scenes in which
part to W be trimmed under sensitive
yeah yeah you guys bombed these scenes
weren't in the movie
you bummed about it if so why not gonna
tell you to put your calm down but if
you want to go for it you can subscribe
to the real rejects please click that
notification about you could follow us
on social media especially at the
Stardust app people 30-second reactions
for any film TV show or trailer I'm
gonna finish up punisher today i'm sure
to review with andrew in a little bit
I'm excited to talk about it but one all
my opinions on it quickly go to Stardust